la guerre contre les voleurs de zébus
elle est menée par des militaires dont
nous suivons un détachement au total ils
sont 1000 à travers toute l'île et déjà
sur la route un peu l'auton de gendarme
exhibent fièrement une première prise
6 gamins
il s'agirait de dalle ils ont 14 15 16
ans tous marqués par l'arrestation
l'un d'entre eux porte le même foulard
rouge et les amulettes que ravak le chef
voleur que nous avions rencontré
je crois que c'est juste parce que
j'avais ces grigri
arrête de mentir en ces temps
d'opération anti voleur de zébus le gris
gris vaut d'abord comme une preuve à
charge
mais qu'il soit simple berger ouvraient
à Halles tous ici croit la magie et aux
vertus de ses amulettes
de choses à l'intérieur des grigri et ça
leur permet de se protéger des balles et
de les éviter
celui là il l'utilise pour se rendre
invisible ces deux là
se ressemblent elles servent à éviter la
fatigue
selon moi c'est clair ce gala est un
dalle un voleur début c'est pour ça
qu'il mette le foulard et la Mulette
ultime preuve brandit par les gendarmes
un fusil fait maison retrouvé chez un
suspect c'est l'arme utilisées par les
Arabes ou les bandits
les pillages il enlève tous les détails
et actuellement ils ont essayé de voler
aussi des marmites et de matelas et tout
ce qui se trouve dans la maison et après
ils enlèvent ils amènent dans la forêt
bien escorté le camion de gendarme par
déposé les 6 adolescents au pénitencier
ces suspects risquent 5 à 10 ans de
prison
dirigé par le capitaine Rodin les
militaires ont pour mission de sécuriser
un village d'une zone très reculée
il pénètre dans la forêt primaire où il
risque une embuscade des gamins voleurs
de zébus
la consigne c'est une distance de 5
mètres entre chaque homme
préparez vos armes
vous rechargez maintenant
c'est bon
c'est dans cette même jungle que les
dalles cachent leurs élus voler et
prépare leurs attaques
sortis du labyrinthe tropical après plus
de 50 km les soldats arrivaient puisés
au village de la baratte pour faire leur
caserne provisoire ils ont réquisitionné
l'école du village
elle avait la présence des militaires
rassure depuis qu'ils sont là les dalles
n'attaquent plus
mais à peine arrivé un problème majeur
resurgit l'opération anti voleur de zébu
a commencé il y a trois mois et les
militaires n'ont jamais été payés
au tableau noir il reprenne leur réflexe
des colliers additions multiplication
les chiffres sont astronomiques
nous on cherche juste à être payé à être
tranquille mais si on n'est pas payé
aujourd'hui on part on s'en fout on
rentre à la maison
il y en a marre maintenant faut qu'on
aille voir les chefs c'est plus possible
on a rien à bouffer
le capitaine Rodin sera trouvé les
quelques rares billets pour éviter la
mutinerie
devant notre caméra les militaires
repartent du bon pied pour suivre la
piste d'un troupeau de zébu volés
les dalles les voleurs agissent dans
l'immensité des plateaux et Forêts ils
ont toujours un temps d'avance sur les
soldats sans hélico sans voiture sans
motos les militaires enquêtes à pied
dans les petits hameaux du coin
bonjour Comment ça va ici et la sécurité
dans le village ça va
oui ça va c'est toute petite communauté
est encore traumatisée récemment ils ont
assisté au plus gros vol de zébus de la
région
juste à côté de notre village et bien
les militaires n'ont jamais retrouvé les
bêtes pas un seul but
dans ce coin de brousse encore une fois
l'armée arrive trop tard